You voted for Trump. What do you mean you want to depolarize
this country? >> Have you thought about how the fact like
the fact that you're subhuman, have you contemplated this in
your brain at all? No, you wouldn't have contemplated it because
you are in FACT A SUBHUMAN
>> I'M SORRY, would you like to win elections or would
you like to be a friend of the internet? >> I I I I I I
I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I I
I I I I I I >> Are you sorry that the person that you empowered
is causing trans people's lives to be demonstrably worse in every
conceivable way? >> Let's stamp that one. That's got the
Wig TV seal of approval right there.
It is the eve of the main Democratic primary and it seems like
Graham Platner is inevitable, guys. Seems like they they want
him in Maine. It is what it is. Oh my god, I hear that Wig panel
is on and none of the people that Wig said had to be there are
there now. I'm guessing it's also just a total like Platner anti-Platner
circle. Listen, this guy is Satan, but we'll vote for him if
we can't get him kicked off, okay? We're going to like totally
totally destroy his campaign as much as possible before the general
and then if we can't get him kicked off the ballot, then I guess
we'll maybe say vote for him, I suppose.
I suppose.
>> Okay. I agree. I think that one of the problems we're
having right now is long-term versus short-term. Um short-term,
if we get the seat, let's say it goes as as great as the the
pro-Platner people or I won't call you pro-Platner, but the blue
no matter who people, right? The blue no matter who people say
we win the seat, we get a Senate majority, we're able to do what
we need to do. I still think that there is an argument and one
I'm leaning towards right now. The long-term damage we do to
our brand, to the party as a whole, to the rhetoric that is seen
as winning, etc. Um that it just makes the world worse and America
worse overall. >> If it was and it was a mistake for Republicans
to vote Trump in in 2016, I think it will also be a mistake to
vote Platner in in 2026.
So, even if he had like uh two allegations against him, rape
>> you'd still >> vote for him. >> Is there
a limit to the number of rape allegations that you It be like,
"Okay, maybe this is too much rape." >> Maybe theoretically.
>> I mean it would have to be really really
really bad. >> I mean my favorite streamer, my favorite
streamer Hutch did say he did say several times that he would
vote for Platner even if it came out that he murdered a man 20
years ago and got away with it. And I know you're being I know
you're being tongue-in-cheek to an
No, I think that is the calculation.
>> Wait, hold on. We actually might have to take a temporary
break. Apparently,
Soy Pill hopped back into that Wick conversation and basically
like [__] on Tally for trying to moralize Book and
Uh-oh.
Am I hearing that
>> After like every Wick panel, you've come to an agreement
and said, "You know what? We're all in agreement on what we should
do with Grand Platner." I just wanted to yell specifically at
Wick and Tally for coming in here and saying, "Oh, don't you
guys think it's bad that like maybe if like they don't get the
Senate majority, then like Grand Platner might reflect bad on
the Democratic Party." Why are we listening to your Trump voting?
Your party is full of
and you voted for them. So, like why are we taking your advice
at all this? >> cuz I don't want the Democratic >> You're
like a stupid Tally. Have you thought about that that you're
like a stupid [__] I W Soy Pill, W Misogyny.
This person's about to lose it, by the Hey Tally, have you thought
about how like I shouldn't care about anything you say? You're
a complete
Have you thought about how the fact like the fact that you're
subhuman? Have you contemplated this in your brain at all? No,
you wouldn't have contemplated it because you are in FACT A SUBHUMAN
[__] I agree Soy Pill. I agree with all of the things
Soy Pill just said, both explicitly and implicitly. Thank you,
Soy Pill. >> party to also be populist
and lack of moral clarity. I actually want to depolarize this
country and have better standards for both parties. >> You
voted for Trump. What do you mean you want to depolarize this
country? >> Yes, and there are plenty of people who want
Grand Platner to get the nomination because they think that he's
going to be easier for someone like Susan Collins to beat. However,
that's not what I want because I don't want people who I >> That's
not even remotely
That's not even remotely responsive to the question asked, stupid.
Okay, I'm not going to get more misogynistic than that. >> morally
defective to >> You voted
>> You voted for Donald Trump. What are you talking about?
>> and I didn't and I didn't do any defense of him. I I
held my nose >> I heard a Trump voter on the panel say
they wouldn't vote for a GOP partner. Can they articulate why
they'd vote for the former but not the hypothetical ladder when
the former is far worse?
You articulate why you vote Yeah, we said this while we were
watching. Obviously the gays. >> I was hoping to be able
to vote for anybody else >> happy with the >> Yeah,
are you happy with Wait, would you take it back? Would you take
it back? >> Would you take it back? >> It's like
every every opportunity you get to talk about this. No, I don't
take back my vote. But this is why we started this conversation.
Okay, is that is that the point you wanted to prove? >> Yeah,
it's that Wick you should stop inviting more into say anything
about it like anything about any party advice when she's like,
"Oh, I don't regret my Donald Trump vote. But you guys are getting
too polarized." Why don't we listen to this Wick? >> Thank
you.
I By the way, I'm just going to say of
if Wick hadn't explicitly endeavored to get me not on this panel,
I would have said the same thing. I said was saying the same
thing while I was While I was watching, I would have said I said
the same thing and now if I were there, I would have said the
same thing to her face, okay? Honestly in honor of Soy Pill and
his sear- seething
undying flame of hatred that he carries for tally bots.
I just would have said it in his honor,
>> I'm sorry, would you like to win elections or would
you like to be a on the internet? I let Tally TALK BECAUSE YOU
SOUND LIKE A [__] right
you would look like a [__] if you had your camera
on, so show face or I'm not going to listen to you. >> Okay,
whatever. Wick has been through this with me. I have camera issues,
>> Oh, you also have issues because of the dumb ass you
said in the first 2 minutes of the debate I listened to, but
go on, make your point. >> Yeah, oh, I'm sorry you didn't
show up for 30 minutes, but you know the first thing I said,
shut the [__] up, you
>> Please go ahead, Tally. And your point? Okay, Tally
can go. >> Oh, I I No, I don't have anything to say >> Yeah,
you shouldn't. That's good. You should say, I'm sorry for what
I did. I made the >> That's awesome. Tally tries to de-escalate.
Good, [clears throat] you shouldn't have anything to say, you
stupid
>> this country worse in every demonstrable way. I'm responsible
in some part for all the bad things that are happening, and you
should never listen to me, and you should spend your entire life
atoning for your stupid decisions, and not be on these panels.
Could you please, please, please at least like consider this
in your life for >> irrational and reasonable. >> If
you had to vote, which is worse?
>> Not only is he rational and reasonable, he might be
under selling a little bit, but he's also funny. You're going
to lose on every every You lose across the board. >> What
Platner uh is alleged to have done with the women >> answer
both questions. Those are the in Maine and in Texas. Make them
answer >> Tally, hold on. Stop. Hold on. >> Wix question
is actually a really good >> Which is worse? What Platner
>> This guy sounds like Tactical Templar. Am I the only
one who hears that? A little bit? >> Uh what Platner uh
is alleged to have >> Yeah, it's it's the slobbering. It's
like the wetness of his speech there that it makes it sound like
Tactical >> answer both questions. Those are the in Maine
and in Texas. Make them answer >> Tally, hold on. Stop.
>> No, that Wix question is actually a really good one.
>> Which is worse? What Platner is alleged to have done
with those women, uh locking them in a room until they calm down,
twisting their arms, physical abuse, or Tally's vote? Which is
worse? >> Tally's vote.
>> Everything that Donald Trump has done is a hundred million
billion times worse than the character of like Plat Grant Platner
has done. And even if we don't get the Senate majority, you're
the opposition of like, well, if we don't get the Senate majority,
we can't have this guy attached to the Democratic Party. I'm
sorry, should we let Susan
>> What? Hey, Soy Pill, what's worse, okay, Brett Ratner
45 prisoners of war in Iraq or Tallybot still breathing? Tallybot
still breathing, not close. Immediate immediate answer, Tallybot
still breathing. That is the problem. It's all >> Susan
Collins remain to be a senator so she can vote in people like
Kavanaugh? Absolutely not. This is ridiculous and the fact that
you're even humoring this as a legitimate position is >> in
Ketanji Brown Jackson. I guess we should have removed her before
she could do that. >> We should have, yes. She should not
have been in there. So just because she's she's right sometimes
>> than 50% of Biden's
federal judge appointments. >> Okay, well she doesn't do
everything horrible but instead we should have a Democrat that's
going to do better things. That's my [__] point.
>> Yes, okay, so what? >> would prefer a moderate
Republican. >> Yes, you would. You would also have preferred
Donald Trump over Kamala Harris because you're a [__]
[__] and we shouldn't listen to you. That's the whole
point. You're like, "Okay, yeah, this guy is a legit
>> I would also rather stop. But like guys, if you do Brett
Ratner, it's going to be just as bad as Donald Trump, a guy I
support and don't regret voting for. Why the [__]
are we listening to you? >> Go ahead. >> I didn't
vote for Trump ever. I have never even seriously considered voting
for >> is your name Tallybot?
>> I didn't say >> who are wrong should shut the
[__] up. I'm not talking to you anymore. >> I'm
saying that her opinion >> I like I like the new off the
plantation pill, okay?
It's like a lot better this way. You love to see it. >> should
be invalidated because of her vote and I am >> Thinking
on whether or not the moral character of someone should be considered
on votes is absolutely [__] ridiculous to be taken
into
>> invalid and that IS WHY YOU >> WELL, NO, MAYBE
NOT. If you're not a Trump voter, maybe you can make a better
argument than Tally can. Maybe we should listen to >> That's
why you lose elections, you >> We should never listen to
independents. >> Well, I don't know. What do you What do
you have to say? Why Why should I listen to you? Cuz you're not
a Trump voter, so you actually have slightly more of a legitimate
basis to be saying what you're saying, so. >> We can go
back to baseline. Uh Muton, I I did give you a lot of uh a lot
of credit early. So, I'm not trying to be a giant aggro over
here. Um, but I In all seriousness,
uh Soy Boy, right? That's That's who I'm talking to, Soy Boy?
>> Um, I Again, I've been getting teased by chat, and that's
fine. I will get teased again. I will say it again. >> I
get teased by chat, so it's all good. >> I'm an I'm an
independent. I'm a
>> Democrat, I am not a leftist. Do you understand me?
Uh, if you understand me, that's all we need to keep saying,
right? But >> in this moment
You're asking me, why am I defending this person? I'm defending
this person because I have been in that same position before,
where I have had to ask myself, which is the actual worst vote?
Right?
Which is actually worse?
And I can be wrong about that. He can be wrong about that. >> If
I am sitting in a position and saying to myself, I don't subscribe
to either team. I think both of you suck. I think you are both
toxic as [__] And I don't want anything to >> I
will call you an idiot because if The both sides guy? Yeah, the
both sides guy is also a [__] [__] Do
any of these things is equivalent, then you're [__]
You can't like analyze empirical data. Yeah. >> Which things?
Which things? >> Uh, like what the Trump administration
is doing versus what the Democrats are doing in the same position.
Hasan, today we just discussed
Stop. You need to rewind the clock to before any of the Trump
stuff happened.
>> He He He looks like so smug and pleased with himself
when he says that.
Hasan said, "They're going to be the same though." Hasan said,
"They're going to be the same
This guy
This guy is just Igor in like in mind, body, and spirit. He's
just Igor. >> It's It's just crazy, man. >> Right?
Okay. Why would I do that? This is absolutely relevant right
now. >> How are you going to vote, right? I don't know
that these things are going to happen. I'm worried about them.
I don't want them to happen. I think >> What What election
are you talking about? 2016? >> I think it's terrible.
>> Who did you vote for in 2020?
>> Who did I vote for in 2020? I did not >> Okay,
so you're you're a moral Why am I listening to you? You don't
understand which party is better. >> I don't know. You
have to actually listen to me, guy. >> I I voted in my
local elections. I >> Listen here, guy. This I want you
to listen to me, guy. >> I did not vote for president in
2020.
I will answer you if you'd like to stop cutting me off.
Is that okay?
>> No, I'll cut you off when I want to, but >> No,
you won't. >> This guy Soyboy is on a bad cycle right now.
Soyboy was He was hitting a plateau at the gym, and he's running
a cycle right now, and he got a bad batch, okay? He's like triple
dosing his cycle, and he's ready to
This guy is on trend right now, and he's ready to tear the limbs
off of anybody who disagrees with him. Holy
>> I don't mind you cutting me off, but I I I don't like
it. >> It's all I'll Look, it's all I'm going to ask I'll
get Joe on to explain >> Oh, no, no, I Wick, you shut the
[__] >> We're We're having a conversation,
and I think this is productive, and and again, I I >> Soyboy
just went and spilled his drink. >> You shut the [__]
up. We're We're having a conversation, and I think this is productive,
and and again, I I'm >> Is it? You think [laughter] this
is productive, Peter? >> this like this pendulum swinging
in your mood is wild, dude. >> I want you to I want you
to answer the question, right? Like I'll answer the question
back, but I want you to answer it to me, right?
Yes, I did not vote in 2020. Why did I not vote in 2020?
>> Feel mad at me. Soyboy, Soyboy, feel mad at me. Soyboy,
Soyboy, Soyboy, could you feel mad at me, Soyboy? >> Because
in 2020 >> Dude, yeah, like I >> I'll be real.
I can't get on these panels, but I do think debasing yourself
to the level that QueenMan has to get onto these panels, it just
it isn't worth it. It's not worth it, okay? I'm sorry. I could
This is too far. Just You just want to get on a wick panel and
you're ready to You're willing to go this far?
That's crazy, man.
That's uncalled for. Nobody wants to see
All right, that's >> I was voting between Biden and Trump,
and I could not
put a finger on who is the worst option. >> fair, this
person may be the only person on Earth I've ever seen that is
more pale than Queenman. I'm I'm not joking. This is like stark
whiteness. This is
That's crazy. This is crazy stuff. >> disagree with me
on that, and it's fine for you to disagree with me on that, but
I'm sure you have similarly said that in congressional elections,
you have similar concerns, where you are just not sure who you
want to put your finger on. >> Yeah, I When I get When
I get unsure, it's between like
>> I realize this is the person behind the the anti-snark
posters. I know. >> You're you're you're you're You're
like three steps behind in this conversation, okay? When I'm
not sure about candidates, it's between two Democrats, one of
which might be a little more progressive than the other, and
maybe they differ on like an Israel vote, and I'm not sure whether
or not the experience matters. You're looking at two people,
one of which demonstrably harms the entire country in awful ways,
and a guy who's going to make it better, and you're like, "Which
one's better?"
>> Okay. Okay, I'm going to I'm I'm I'm >> Also,
I mean, if you're just going to go off of rumors with no substantiated
evidence, Donald Trump's been accused of assault like 50 times.
Like, if you're just going to go off of accusations, Gran Planer
is still orders of magnitude better, anyway. If you're just going
off of accusations of personal conduct.
Like, it's Even if you want to go into that dimension, it's still
orders of magnitude different, so I It's just no >> Okay.
So, I felt you have anything else for anyone else in the panel?
>> Um no. Well, unless >> off, Wick? >> Yeah,
I can get me out of here. I mean, >> Oh, kick him off,
Wick. Don't pretend like you're not having fun, Wick. >> I'm
having >> I want to make sure other people get a chance.
>> What do we do these panels for? >> I don't know.
Well, she's right. What's your What's your position? I forgot
your pronouns was. I was too angry to >> I am not pushing
it. I'm not pushing it. >> It's not your turn to talk,
PvP. Um it is my position that I think Tully is correct in pointing
out there is a moral difference in the conduct between parties
because she does know and expect that we are better people than
she holds herself to. And Tully, my trans friend herself, because
of the man you empowered, are you sorry? >> Oh, I'm so
GLAD I REWOUND. I DID not know she did that. No way. Dude, you
can tell this person was like very very very sorry, right? You
can tell this person was very sorry. >> Apologize.
MY FRIEND MY FRIEND JUMPED OFF A BRIDGE, AND YOU'RE LAUGHING.
>> As someone who was formerly a therapist, I think it
is very dangerous to attribute uh motivations to any single person
or event. So, I'm terribly sorry that your friend themselves.
That's horrible.
>> Absolutely horrible. >> Is So, I felt he's going
to jump on. So, I felt he's going to pile on. No way. >> Okay,
you didn't say you didn't state the gender, so I didn't know.
Okay, then I didn't hear. >> So, I'm terribly sorry that
your friend themselves. That's horrible.
>> Absolutely horrible. >> Okay, you didn't say you
didn't state the gender, >> Corrected themself to yourself.
>> Yes, I didn't know. Okay, then I didn't >> Dude,
how do we get off this panel when it turned into such insane
content,
>> I heard I heard you say my trans friend. That's what
I heard. >> Tully said something allegedly transphobic.
That's crazy. I wouldn't expect that from her. >> No, it's
fine. >> I'm I'm terribly sorry for the loss of your friend.
Terribly sorry. That's >> that the person that you empowered
is causing trans people's lives to be demonstrably worse in every
perceivable
>> Um I definitely don't agree everything that the Trump
administration >> Listen, are you you you asked me something
Germany 1940, okay? Are you comfortable with the fact that the
the leader you elected is making the lives of across Germany
worse in every tangible way? Well, I don't agree with everything
Hitler's doing, but have you seen the parades, man? Have you
seen the uniforms? I don't agree with everything, but come on.
Maybe the guy has a point. That's all I'm saying. >> is
pushing in regards to trans health care and things like that.
>> Okay. So, but you're okay with it. You won't you don't
regret it. You do agree >> with some of it. Certainly,
I definitely agree with some of it, yeah. >> Which parts?
>> I agree >> I agree with banning uh >> Oh
my god.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's so good. It's so good. >> transition under the
age of 18, and I agree with prioritizing sex over gender in law
where relevant.
>> Okay. But but then would you Wait, hold on. No, it doesn't
matter. We don't have to get in the minutia of that. She's she's
right, right? Because she's saying, "I'm willing to do all the
other stuff, bathroom bans, uh you know, affirming care bans,
medication bans, passport revocations." All of that's okay with
you as long as those things that you do agree with happen, right?
>> No, and not all of those things are happening or going
to happen, and certainly not everything >> [__]
happening. Shut the [__] up. Are you being serious?
Okay. Okay. Okay. Oh, it's not >> Okay, I want I want it
>> just close our eyes and ears and say it's not happening.
>> And I think part of part of being in an in an No one
agrees with every single thing that either side of the aisle
does. This is just a true thing that we all know and accept.
When our party is the one making >> I want to make sure
Hold on. I I accept what that things happen to the Democrats,
but I cuz I want to protect trans people. You don't give Imagine
just being so arrogant that you can't go, "Yeah, I [__]
up voting for Trump." Like, wouldn't you just say you regret
your Trump vote on the corruption
Like, it shouldn't take the trans person going, "Are you Are
you okay with the person you empowered make my friend kill themselves?"
That shouldn't give giving you pause at all. Just the corruption
by itself is like enough to go, "Yeah, that was a [__]
up. My bad."
I don't understand How does she stand on business on this? I
I don't get it. You can't be an intelligent human being and stand
on
on this one. >> Vishy gets a chance to have his statement,
so maybe maybe, you know, give some other callers a chance. It's
Vishy, what do you have to say? >> Dude Dude, Wick is sweeping.
Oh my god.
Bro, Tally was getting Tally was getting mauled right there,
and Wick just totally changes the topic in the middle of his
own content. That's why he shouldn't be doing this cuz in the
middle of his own in the middle of his own content,
okay, Wick's trying to touch that thigh.
>> Wick's going to get Wick's going to get a little thigh
for himself, isn't he? He's looking for a little thigh action
right now. >> Vishy, I got to talk to you. I got to talk
to you, brother. What are you doing? >> Crap. I'm not trying
to be the center of attention, okay? >> I Well, you I know
I'm vocal. >> You're okay. >> No, it's not that.
It's your It's your Okay, I don't want to be mean. What are your
actual principles? Because it seems that you just have none.
Like genuinely, what do you care about politics? You say you
want us to get out >> What do you mean pri- His name is
principles over politics.
Come on. Come on. >> you to get off of your ass to vote.
But you don't care about policy. >> Wait, this guy came
out, the Vishy guy. >> I'm pretty sure I've seen him before.
>> Well, that's that's a fair criticism.
>> I Okay, if it's unfair, I still I don't understand that
because >> Well, no, I didn't I didn't say it was unfair.
I said it's >> Anyone thinks this is a hug box right now,
I don't know what to tell you. You Well, it's a hug box cuz you
changed the topic when Tally was getting pressed on being a total
[__] on being somebody nobody should respect or care
about the opinion of.
Like directly getting All of your content was being provided
to you for
It's fair. >> Yeah. So, then why the [__] would
we want you to vote at all? Why would YOU WHY WOULD YOU Why would
we want your vote at all then? To get you off your ass. If you
just don't care about policy, what's the point?
>> You're over here like, "I'm the independent, non-partisan."
But then you >> Hey, yeah, tease me as much as you want
to, dude. I'll give you a solid answer. You want my answer?
>> It's not going to be solid, but sure. >> Oh, it
will be solid. Do you want to know what my actual principles
are? Because this is going to tell you why I will not vote for
Platner under any
>> It's It's under two categories, and this is why I've
been harping on the the independent aspect, because yeah, sometimes
you're going to look at it and you're going to go, "Well, that's
inconsistent. That doesn't make sense." And I'm just going to
say back to you, "You haven't thought about it hard enough."
Right?
My principles >> Why Why not just explain it then? You
haven't thought about it hard enough. Why not just explain? >> Hold
on. >> are liberal and conservative. If you understand
If you If you understand the actual meaning of those terms, liberal
and conservative. Yes, I am Chesterton's fence, but I am also
liberal. I am very much in your lane if you are a Democrat, and
that is why I get offended when you ask me to vote for you when
you're doing things that make me say, "I have absolutely nothing
>> Oh god. >> in common with you." >> It's
a counterpoint's viewer, isn't it? >> Oh, no, [laughter]
we have things in common. We have things in common. I can have
that fight. We can have that fight. General public doesn't know
what does and doesn't make sense. What we We don't have anything
in common. We have a >> What do you mean you didn't vote
for Biden? Why didn't you vote for Biden?
>> In 2016, and again, this is where I'm going to ask you
guys to rewind the clock, right? >> I'm talking 2020. >> No,
I know. I know you're talking 2020. >> You have to put
yourself >> Why didn't you vote for Biden? >> In
2016, I'm talking about 2020. Yeah, nobody votes that? Yeah,
it's when he ran? Give us the the the the >> I know. I
know, Wick. I know. >> No, you >> You have to put
yourself in my mind space, because in that vote >> January
6th >> That Shut the [__] up. January 6th had
not happened yet. In that mo- >> Bro, he's like, "I'm going
to ask you a direct question. In 2016,
my life story begins with a an anecdote from 2016.
It is I you know, I love Connor, but it's it is like a counterpoint
viewer. It's like a Connor Yeah, this is like a Connor imitation
Connor skin walking right now. It's not good. >> Yeah,
January 6th was what happened. January 6th had not happened yet.
>> In 2024 did you vote for Kamala? >> I would. I
am not arguing with you >> You're like one tier above Talley.
All right, cool. >> Sure, but I'm asking why does January
6th matter? Why didn't you vote Why didn't you vote for Biden?
Why didn't he earn your vote? What policy did you have a disagreement
on? >> Policy doesn't matter. >> But that in that
in that moment
>> I was as worried that Democrats were >> Policy
doesn't matter. What What the
>> to do stupid [__] as I was worried that
Republicans were going to do stupid >> But you just got
off Trump's absolute crazy presidency, his wild ride, Mr. Bones'
wild ride that we were on for 2016 to 2020, and you were like,
"Well, you know, Biden would probably be just as bad." >> I'm
not trying to argue. He just said policy doesn't matter. Are
we supposed to like >> Yeah, the dude, what the Policy
doesn't matter at all.
>> So let me make a little more money if you guys are going
to >> I say policy doesn't matter what >> No, wait,
also again, you [laughter] talked about Okay, also I just want
to know that you don't know or understand politics. You talked
about Clyburn and the reason he doesn't uh retires because he
has seniority on committees. He is not the ranking on any committee.
He's on appropriations, and he is the ranking on a subcommittee.
It doesn't matter. The reason he stays is because literally South
Carolina Republicans don't want Like they won't even write him
out cuz they know he will win. Second like a second off, again,
like I still just don't understand how you say you have principles
that's liberal liberal and conservative. When again, okay, wait,
would you vote for Platner if it meant like 5 million lives would
be saved? >> Well, let me take let me unpack that one >> Hey,
before you do that, I want to read some chats because you guys
are going to make a little money off of this. >> I know
that really hard question. 5 million lives
I know. Center of attention is my money right now. >> $10
for $4 from Potter Politics. I heard a Trump voter on the panel
say they wouldn't vote for a GOP Platner. Can they articulate
why they'd vote for the former, but not the hypothetical latter
when the former is far worse? >> That's a great question.
>> Yeah, so first of all, it has to do to a certain extent
with the credibility of the allegations and things of this nature.
Um >> Just size of >> Mark, um I just can't comment.
I Like honestly, I just know I think too much.
I I Yeah, I can't comment. It just is what it is. >> And
what I didn't that I didn't necessarily believe all the allegations
against Joe Biden. I am weighing the credibility of some of these
allegations. Um but also
Yeah, I don't know. I think I think Platner is a more disgusting
person. I think like I would I would rather leave my uh small
daughter in a room with Donald Trump and Glenn Platner. That's
how I FEEL.
>> BRO. OH,
WE'RE ON TWITCH. I have to be very, very careful with the TOS.
Very, very careful with the TOS, okay? I'm I'm sorry.
And I'm I'm going to take it one step further. I'm actually going
to take it one step further right now. The only thing she cares
about is her her identity, her ethnicity. That's literally all
she cares about. That's the only way you could have this
I'm sorry. That's the only way you could have that opinion.
It's very obvious, very clear. I don't I don't think there's
any further analysis that needs to happen.
It's just that simple, okay?
>> I don't know. >> You're being consistent. What
are we What are we talking about? >> I'm sorry if that's
not satisfying. I actually believe that. >> You're the
guys who would Wait, the guy who would want to walk into underage
changing rooms? You would Okay, never [laughter] mind. Back to
PBP. What do you think about it? >> Okay, no, I got more
super chats. No, we're not we're not I'm >> I'm going to
answer >> It's a $5 from Cinabon bon bon bon pup to say
the documented brutal sexual assault of his ex-wife is more horrific
than what Platner has been accused of. Tully being good with
Trump but not Platner says a lot. >> Yeah, just so you
know, Tully, I don't know, maybe cuz you don't really like research
or or learn things or look into this stuff. Like Donald Trump's
>> How many times you going to call her just a stupid
How many times, Soy Pill?
I I feel like Soy Pill Soy Pill is going to imply the word at
some point. I feel like it's I feel it. He's going to say something.
He'll never say the word directly, but he's going to imply it
very heavily at some point coming up. I can feel it. You'll feel
the the back The hairs in the back of your neck will stand up.
He will he'll say it at some point here. I can feel it. >> That's
what I said. He beat me. And it wasn't like a retraction in so
far as like, no, that didn't happen." It was, "Well, maybe like
that There's like under certain definitions." But you look into
it and he It's not, "Oh, he put his hand on her." Or he said
he would become an intruder and it terrified her a little bit
or like whatever Platner's being accused of, which is not good.
It's just straight up like this happened. And then he buried
her on the golf course cuz he So, I don't know how you can say
one of these is like not obviously worse. >> He's also
a convicted >> Okay, $2 from >> Well, and he did
This is true. >> to say Mouten is a traitor to the >> Not
in criminal court and that does matter with the type of >> civilly
liable for assault. >> The evidence is >> I couldn't
hear I couldn't hear.
>> I mean, personally, I just feel like you don't leave
your daughter in a room with Trump, your young daughter, because
of the comments about Ivanka when she was under age. Probably
that's like the start and end of it, right? If this guy was barely
able to hold himself back from assaulting his own daughter, what
do you think is going to save your
I'm just saying.
Do you think that's
>> This is why he doesn't like policy because it's a thousand
things. He's like, "Woah." He doesn't know what to do. He just
votes on vibes, you know? >> Oh, shut the [__]
up, you idiot.
>> All right, go on. Go on. Again, you you want to You
want to You want to answer the question. And I apologize. Remind
me the quest The exact question you're >> Okay, would you
vote for Platner if you let me finish my sentence? Would you
vote for Platner in the general if he's there if it meant saving
10 million lives? Absolutely not. >> Uh well, let me Sorry,
I think I misunderstood your question, but I You heard it You
heard the confidence with which I answered. And if I if I got
it backwards, then you understand what I was saying. If it meant
saving 10 million lives, then yeah, I would I would I would bite
that bullet. >> Okay. Okay. Okay. Let me
>> Would you Would you vote against
>> Would you Hold on. Stop. Stop. Yeah, I understand. But
I got a question for those two. It's a It's a counter question.
Would you vote against Platner to save 10 million MAGA lives?
>> Would you >> Damn, that's a hard one, actually.
>> Wait, I can vote for Platner and get rid of some of
the worst scum in the entire country. HOLD ON. HOLD
ON.
probably you say vote against, but holy That's uh
I
envy those with the strength to just, you know, make that decision
with their >> I don't want to kill Tally. I'll say that.
I think she's a [__] I think she shouldn't be taken
seriously. I do not want to kill her, okay? Everyone deserves
redemption, no matter how How times they [__] up
over and over and over again, okay? >> Okay, now on to
January 6th. How many of them went there? >> Wait, BB,
let me make it real more >> Well, let me finish. >> Let
me finish. >> Can I ask the follow-up, which is cuz you're
using the word "realistic" >> BB, what BB, is it not realistic
that Graham Platner being in the Senate majority, if we get rid
of the filibuster, could absolutely be the stopgap to getting
US aid back and maybe saving 10 million lives? Like it's not
even a hypothetical, it's literally a thing that could happen.
>> Yes. Well, I'm sorry, we're like 6 degrees down a hypothetical
and it's not a hypothetical. >> Wait, wait, wait, no, no,
this is a very real thing that has been >> Are you Are
you Do you Are we talking about >> what US aid is? >> If
he wins and he does this and this and this, are we being the
only Senate >> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. >> Yeah,
I know, it's >> like 6 degrees >> We think of our
guest as >> Trump has been found liable by a jury of his
peers and the ruling has survived multiple appeals and it's been
more substantiated and scrutinized than the allegations against
Platner. How is Trump better? >> Give me fire.
>> Josiah told me he couldn't make this panel, but he's
watched the entire panel and donated the whole time.
>> If this liar does the things that I expect HIM TO DO,
OH, YEAH, WAIT, WAIT, IT'S GOING TO WORK OUT PERFECTLY. YEAH,
if we lived in Candyland, WE WOULD BE IN CANDYLAND. >> WAIT,
WHERE DID he lie ever about like voting anything red? Tell me
what policy he's ever >> We don't have time to talk about
it. >> What policy has he ever >> I tried to look
it up before the show. >> WHAT [laughter] WHAT WHAT NO,
NO, LOOK LOOK LOOK LOOK LOOK LOOK HAS he ever stopped sloppying
BUT WHAT HAS HE EVER GONE AWAY FROM THAT? EVER? And of all this
words, he's always been the sloppiest. Why do you think HE'S
GOING TO GO, "OH, I'M ELECTED." >> NO, I DON'T HAVE TIME.
>> [__] LIAR BECAUSE HE DOESN'T >> OKAY,
OKAY, OKAY. >> WHAT HE CARES ABOUT THE MOST >> BB,
you got to We got to cycle you out, >> Wait, wait, wait,
one more question, one more question, I'll leave. Would you make
it more realistic, would you vote for him if it's a reverse one
big beautiful bill act?
>> I help me understand what Okay, no, we're not doing
this. BB, BB, BB, BB, that's not realistic. That's [laughter]
a 6 degree hypothetical. Like imagine a video that's one and
then two is voting, that's two and then like four other things
might happen. >> What the beautiful bill act, if you actually
paid attention to last year, was the one that did like that basically
made ICE, what is it, the 15th largest military or whatever,
the one that did all of the Medicaid cuts, the one that did the
like it was the big bill, a big bill that basically one
>> I have no idea who I I don't know who is I had no idea
any of these people are going to be on the panel, not Hutch >> I
know it was the big bill, but you got to understand I I I >> You
don't follow politics. >> I Well, no, I know this or that
that's in it, but in this exact moment I yes, I have just been
yelling at you. I'm not arguing, okay? Again, just like I said
to Mouton, I'm not trying to be a but in this moment, I I'm trying
to understand you, okay? So, you're saying it What is What is
this thing that I'm supposed to vote against? >> Okay,
the big beautiful bill, which cut millions of people off healthcare,
which expanded ICE, which did a lot of things that ostensibly
a Democrat would oppose, right? Would you vote for Grant Platner
if they would reverse that using Grant Platner's part of the
Senate majority that Democrats would have?
>> Okay, so why are you arguing against voting for Grant
Platner when all of these things are things that Democrats are
promising to do? >> Well, because we're talking about a
gigantic thing that is different. Thank you.
Thank you. You understand. You understand, right? It's It's not
that I'm not trying to bat for your team. It's that I'm not literally
on your team. Does that make sense?
If If you're posing it in the in the context of here are the
specific things that I am opposed to that I would prefer that
you oppose, I will absolutely sign up with you. >> What
do you What do you oppose the Democrats doing?
>> Wait, say that again. >> What do you oppose that
the Democrats >> Read my super chat.
>> What policy do you oppose that the Democrats oppose?
>> I don't think Soy Pill should have played. I don't think
Soy Pill was supposed to be on the panel. >> This is since
about policy. >> Okay, what What do you invite these people
on? >> $10 from Skeptic Ninja. >> This is about what
they're doing to the party. This is what you are doing to every
other Democrat. It has absolutely nothing to do with Grant Platner
specifically. It has everything to do >> because when you
oppose the material conditions that will happen, you say I will
vote for Grant Platner, which is all the things that will happen
if you >> No, you're sitting here purity testing me, and
I'm telling you >> I promise cuz I would be willing to
vote for a guy with a Nazi tattoo. I'm not purity testing >> But
I have to do this >> It's that or the other thing. >> Yes,
I will give you some answer. >> Let's Yeah, I don't know
why you guys are interrupting my money. >> This guy, I'm
not voting for him, and I >> know why you guys are interrupting
my money right now. $10 from Skeptic Ninja. >> What? Why?
Can't Wick just shut the [__] up and let the content
flow? Why the [__] is Wick I thought you usually
wait for your super chats.
Bro, just let the content flow for a second, dog. >> say,
"What is Polly's logic of Trump being civilly convicted making
the great less bad, but Platner not being convicted at all and
only being accused is so much worse?" I'm not saying that an
accusation is worse than than a finding from a civil court. I'm
talking about the credibility of different allegations and the
standards of evidence. And no, his abuse his alleged victims
have not taken this to court as far as we know. The two women
who have accused him of assault have not gone public with their
names. So, we'll see how all of this plays out. I'm talking about
credibility of allegations and there can be both credible and
non-credible allegations against a
>> What are the credible allegations against Grant Platner
is the question somebody should ask this stupid person.
Oh, I didn't I didn't even get misogynistic there. This stupid
And then we're going to get to we're going to get to
Rydell in a second. $20 from the Pontificating Politics. 4 minutes
behind. Trump was found liable by a jury of his peers. The ruling
has survived multiple appeals and it's been more substantiated
and scrutinized than the allegations against Platner. How is
Trump better? Rydell, what you >> You think that was similar?
>> Yeah, it was. Yeah, but you didn't answer. You you basically
Hey, I don't understand how you could possibly think this thing.
Well, you know, there's different standards of
Yeah, you didn't like answer the question or get any closer to
actually telling me what the [__] going on
Yeah, there's different standards of evidence, man.
Cool. Uh thank you. Th- thank you. Alice, what do you need? >> Um
yeah, because of the program cuts in the big bad bill, my disabled
mother, um whose health care would be cut out with no alternatives,
took her life on November 1st. Are you sorry, Talley?
Am I sorry for the loss of your mother?
>> Oh my god.
>> Alice, what do you need? >> Um yeah, because of
the program cuts in the big bad bill, my disabled mother, um
whose health care would be cut out with no alternatives, took
her life on November 1st. Are you sorry, Talley? >> She's
got another She's got another friend. Sorry, IT'S HER MOM. HER
MOM KILLED HERSELF because of Trump, too.
Bro, how many people around this woman are committing
What the [__]
This is This is her mom. Before it was her friend, her trans
friend who killed themselves. Now it's her mom. What the
there's no way.
Dude, this is crazy. I How awesome would it be if this person
just goes on every single panel and is just like,
"I hold you responsible for my mom and my friends themselves.
So many people died because of Trump.
Don't you feel any shame?" Dude, that would be awesome for the
rest of for the rest of time.
No, the the trans friend is very different from the mom who is
disabled and lost her her Medicare or her coverage because the
big beautiful bill.
>> Wait, is this highest quality we can go?
This [__] Okay.
Um yeah, because He's already laughing before she asked the question.
He's already laughing. program cuts in the big bad bill, my disabled
mother, um whose health care we cut out with no alternatives,
took her life on November [clears throat] 1st. Are you sorry,
>> I saw you smile. I saw you smile. You see his You see
his mouth open up there? Hold on, hold on, hold on. He's trying
so hard not to laugh. I have to play it again. Wait, did I mute?
Did I mute?
Right there. Right there. You see his mouth go up towards smiling?
Lips curling? He's trying so hard to remain stone-faced.
Can he do it? Can he do it? I'm sorry for the loss of your mother,
of course. That's terrible. I'm not going to You can't keep trying
to pin the death of people in your life to me. Are you sorry
for voting to enable this? I'm very sorry for the death of your
mother. I'm terribly sorry. Are you sorry? Dude, I would not
be able to. I would not be able to. I would lose it. That's why
I can't come up. I have no facial discipline at all. I would
die. I would actually die laughing at this person in the middle
of a panel. I I facial discipline whatsoever. I can't control
like if I find something funny, I'm going to I'm going to roll
over, okay? I I can't do it. I can't do it. That was impressive
from Soy Pill to be honest with you. I can't believe he just
held it in like that, man. >> You vote to have her mother
died again? You would vote to have her mom died again, right?
>> I don't I don't accept that. I'm sorry. I'm not going
to going to accept her so >> how voting works. That's how
voting works. That's how voting works. That's how voting works.
That's how voting >> I'm terribly sorry.
>> No, but you would you would let your but you but you
have it happen again. Say it. Stop being a coward. >> Soy
Pill's like riling her up, too. He would do it again. HE WOULD
KILL MAMA AGAIN. He would kill >> mama again. >> And
coward say, "I'm willing to let your mom die for the policies
>> You're not going to You can't keep trying to pin the
death of people in your life to me. >> Are you sorry for
voting to enable this? >> I'm very sorry for the death
of your mother. I'm terribly sorry. >> Would you vote to
have her mother died again? You would vote to have her mom died
again, right? >> I don't I don't accept that. I'm sorry.
I'm not going to going to accept her so >> how voting works.
That's how voting works. That's how voting works. That's how
voting works. That's how voting >> I'm terribly sorry.
>> No, but you would you would let your but you You are
not sorry. You would do it
Uh but you have it happen again. Say it. Say it. Stop being a
Coward say, "I'm willing to let your mom die for the >> No,
I refuse to accept that. Why are you Why do you refuse? Because
you're a coward? And you say that the 79 million people who voted
for Trump are responsible for the death of your mother. I'm >> I'm
probably Soy Pill. You're going to make Soy Pill's going to amp
this woman up until she cries. This is [__] up. I
couldn't do this, okay? I could never do something like what
Soy Pill's doing right now. I certainly didn't make a ton of
money doing this exact thing to other people in a totally morally
black way like like 2 years ago. I certainly would never do anything
like this. >> I'm sorry. I don't
Very convenient that you don't think you're responsible I'm terribly
sorry that your mother died. That's terrible.
>> There is a very high chance that first of all, Platter
won't win against Collins. Collins has won by being behind more
than she is now and I think 2020 she was down 12 points in November
but she ended up winning by my close on that bet. >> All
the hold on.
>> Yeah, I I throw down a I probably throw down four figures
in this to be honest with you on a Platter win. I'm not even
joking. Like I I think it's just that obvious to me that if Platter
doesn't
Platter will win in the general. >> I I I I despair of
winning the seat so that's one and so I will not I will not put
my credibility on the line to support someone who's going to
lose anyway with all these allegations. >> you just have
to make up an area where she's guaranteed to lose therefore I
don't have to vote and absolve yourself of all responsibility.
You you can just say oh it's fine I don't have to vote because
she's going to win.
>> I just think like even if she's down like five or six
in the polls she's going to win anyway so I'm not going to bother
at all.
Is the WIC TV position.
That's the WIC TV position guys. Let's stamp that one. That's
got the WIC TV seal of approval right there.
Amazing stuff WIC.
>> What's going to happen is if Platter becomes a nominee
and goes and and and wins, right? Everyone nationally is going
to run against Platter. He's going to be the guy >> Fantastic.
Run against Platter you're going to get steam rolled.
Run against Platter. Run against the guy who is arguing that
it's [__] up that there's more wealth generation
happening in America than ever but you can't afford to get Christmas
presents for your kids. Run against that guy. See what happens
man. I please run against that guy. I pray you run against that
guy nationally and see what happens. I'm sorry it's not These
people still aren't getting it that there are people struggling.
People are struggling a lot. It's It's not a joke.
It has been a joke. People will joke back like eight years ago
I feel like even people were saying, "Well, I can't even live
on six figures in New York City." And everybody would laugh at
them, right? That's like a common common story now. People are
not doing okay.
>> They paint as the Democrats. And it's going to hurt
us for a long time down ticket. It absolutely >> What do
you think of Worst Wick?
>> If Platner wins and you had a crystal ball and you could
look into the crystal ball and you could see that if Platner
wins, we are going to lose the Senate in
and then we're going to go on and >> Yes, I would not vote
for Platner if voting for Platner would cause all the worst things
to happen. >> Would you vote for Platner if if you found
out that Russia would nuke America in 2029?
See? Well,
why would you vote for him then? >> Because that's a stupid
thing to say or
Yeah, it's I'm sorry. He's not introduced a significantly more
believable hypothetical than I just did. He's just a He's just
trying to come up with reasons. >> In this hypothetical
specifically that ensures that voting for Platner makes bad things
happen. >> Yeah, I I think there's a good chance that voting
for Platner would make bad things happen.
I think that he getting into power, right? And becoming uh one
of the national faces of the Democratic Party means we will lose
long-term more often than even even if we take a hit this this
electoral season, that we will have better chances longer term
if we don't make someone who had a Nazi tattoo and lied about
it one of our That's it. >> Based on what? >> Okay,
based on >> Sorry, based on what? Based on the fact that
he had a a Nazi tattoo and lied about it.
>> I think we'll have a bad time if we elect somebody who
had a Nazi tattoo and lied about it. Based on what? Based on
the fact that he HAD A NAZI TATTOO and lied about it. Yeah, I
uh fantastic. We got the 110 combined IQ between Wick and this
I don't know. >> Based on what are you saying that we're
going to lose in the future election? >> Because I think
that I know this is this is this is my intuition here. >> Please
shut up. You keep getting this
>> You just got to let me You got to let me answer these
people. Based on my >> Maybe you look like Wick if you
turn your camera on. >> Yeah, based on my intuition that
people do not like
the people who would otherwise vote Democrat, I should say. I
won't talk about MAGA here. Do not like people who have Nazi
tattoos and lie about it, abuse women, all these things. >> They
will stay home. >> They will stay home when All the Republicans
will have to do is they will have to play a reel of all of the
Democrats who are endorsing Platner, who are standing by and
sticking by him and calling him the worst man in all this. And
they will tie that to our hands. >> Do you want them to
play a reel of the Department of Homeland Security's Twitter
doing a bunch of like pretty much Nazi propaganda? >> Why
do you think Trump's losing? >> Hold on. >> Stop.
Stop. This is >> Why do you think >> Hold on. Shut
up. >> Trump's losing because he started the war with Iran.
Honestly, Trump wasn't even doing that badly when he was just
doing the ice stuff. The ice stuff once they killed Renee Good
was bad, but realistically, the signaling for ice, bro, he wasn't
even falling off that hard, man. It was It was not even that
bad. It's quite literally Iran and price increases. That's what's
going to ask Republicans.
>> Trump's losing because we're currently in a war with
Iran. >> Well, one of the There's a lot of reasons he's
losing, but one of the reasons Democrats are projected to win
is because MAGA is behaving in the way that you want me to sign
on for Platner, >> Platner is not doing what he's doing.
He's not doing the crazy It's all in his past, and as bad as
it is, it's not doing what the current administration is doing.
But Wick >> Only because he doesn't >> And you're
giving You're giving way too much credence to a Senate race in
terms of overall notoriety for how people vote in the elections
period. Most of it is based off the account >> Why is Wick
so involved in this combo? Because if he stops talking, So he
feels going to start asking Tallybots why she's such a again,
and Wick is trying to draw aggro cuz again, he's trying to get
a thigh touch in. >> No, no. >> Is that [laughter]
>> No, no. >> Like you were talking about. We don't
even have to go that far.
Ain't nothing Wick love more than No, no, no.
I can't. I can't. >> Would the dispositive to your argument
not be that he won in the general and clearly this is not hurting
the Democrats if the people of Maine, the people who have the
most information about all of the worst things that he's done
would vote for him over Susan Collins, clearly it does not matter
and this isn't going to make us lose Senate races in states where
people don't know who the [__] Platner is? >> I
think that they're going to learn who Platner is when the Republican
>> What are they going to learn in six years from now that
they don't know now? >> machine is effective.
>> Uh for taking down Grand Platner? No, it's not working
very well. >> Hey, they're not trying to take down Platner.
They're promoting him. Why do you think that's is? >> What
do you mean they're promoting him? >> They're absolutely
promoting They promoted him in the primary. >> They absolutely
promoted him. >> What What the [__] is this
[__]
What is What is the Fang of Zion saying?
But they're promoting him. How?
>> The Republican machine making Grand Platner look good.
>> Again, when When he wins an official locks in this nomination,
they're going to go and drop everything they have against this
guy. But until he does, they're doing the same thing that we
did in 2022 and they're promoting the people that they think
will lose, right? Like if the DNC >> Where is he being
promoted by Republicans, Wick? Wick, where are the Republicans
promoting him? Wick, where are the Republicans promoting him?
Wick, Wick, Wick. The The What is the leaning The ideological
leaning of The Daily Caller? Who published the article saying
that the New York Times published a soft
Pretty sure The Daily Caller is like a Republican rag, no? >> DNC
promoted a lot of the extremist MAGA so that we they could lose
in the general. That's what the Republicans >> they're
promoting him? Now? Can you show me where they're promoting him
now? >> I can find it for you. >> YOU'RE DOING IT
RIGHT NOW, YOU [__]
>> I'M A REPUBLICAN?
>> BRO. WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT? >> But yes, Republicans
are getting
>> The guy actually Holy [__] the guy was dumb
enough that he understood why he was dumb this time. Oof. That's
rough. That's rough. >> Leave it Platner is the nominee.
>> Wick Wick, okay. When they make these accusations, the
when is when are these >> the [__] up and you
you you actually explain to the rest of us that everybody understands
what the [__] you're talking about. Which accusations?
Which accusations? Because some of the >> So, accusing
>> of them are not. And I would like you to explain to
the rest of us what the [__] we're actually talking
about so that we can stop screaming at each other. >> Um
you're the only one screaming right >> Yeah, I know I am.
Shut the [__] up. >> So, maybe so the Nazi
tattoo thing. This was not be a hey, he's a crazy left-winger
guy. Hey, this guy is like, you know, super pro-trans like the
they/them attacks in 2024, okay? This is like, hey, if you say
this to some of your Republican people, might vote for them.
By the way, it's good to see you. So, I'm confused as like, okay,
yeah, sure. I'm very aware the Republican media machine is very
good at taking crazy people that they use the SJWs. They, you
know, got Tally on board, so you know, she's susceptible. She's
a third-level susceptible to propaganda. But what would they
do for Platner that's going to make independents and
>> Dude, I I love when people are unhinged and obsessed.
And Joey Pill is unhinged and obsessed about Tally. He's just
going to every single time he goes to talk, just a quick reminder,
guys. So, listen. Republican strategy goes like something like
this and this and this and Tally box is a stupid and just I'll
get back to my topic now. >> And right-wingers go, "Woah,
I wouldn't vote for this guy. He might vote for the home intruder.
He's like really, you know, controlling and abusive towards women
like I am because I'm a like trad cath." Like, where is this
coming from? Where is this working? It's not the MAGA people
that are going to stop voting for Trump. It's the people that
are going to stop voting for Trump. So, I'm not talking to you.
I'm talking to Wic. You keep making You keep making this mistake.
You want to say Wic, I'm talking to this guy. He says Wic. Your
name's not Wic, so I want Wic to stop talking to you. >> That's
true. That is that is correct. >> Joey Pill is correct
in that. So, here's the problem. It's not like they're not going
to turn him off to the trad caths, MAGA crazy people. That's
not what's going to happen. It's going to be to the more moderate,
center-right, center-left leaning people who are just going to
stay home. The people who like, I don't like Trump.
>> That's what I'm saying. I'm not yelling at you for no
reason. WHY WOULD SOMEBODY STAY HOME? BECAUSE I STAYED HOME.
BECAUSE I'M WILLING TO SAY THAT. >> You stayed home during
2020, okay? You're willing to stay home for anything, all right?
>> Oh, for anything. Oh, yeah, yeah, >> I was scared
of Joe Biden. >> I failed to vote 2016. I failed to vote
>> Oh, yeah, I had absolutely
>> He didn't vote in 2020, the easiest year of all time
to vote, where mail-in ballots were allowable, were allowed from
every like basically every single
Literally the easiest year to vote, he didn't vote. The [__]
going on, man? >> I hate everybody.
>> Is he drunk? >> I got a quick question, Wicker.
>> To everybody on the panel, would you rather Trump 2016
or 2024 Trump as your >> Did Destiny Destiny feed you that
one? I'm genuinely curious. >> How do you ask the actual
question, which Trump >> Which one? >> Uh, 2016 Trump,
absolutely.
>> So, maybe I'm interpreting the the question differently
from Wicker. If we're talking about comparing the administrations,
the presidencies, then yes, I would prefer 2016 Trump. But in
terms of like the the
candidate, I they were more appealing people around him. Yeah,
for me personally in 2024. But I would agree that the first administration
was >> There were more people Who were those appealing
people? What?
What the
Who were the more appealing people around Trump? Like RFK?
>> That's like the same. >> That's wild, but okay.
All right. Alex >> I am just telling you how I feel. I
don't know what
>> Wick, I swear to god
Soy Pill's like Soy Pill's sitting here and he's like talked
all this [__] about stupid how subhuman Talibot is.
And she just exceeded all of his previous expectations.
Like Soy Pill is honestly talking all this [__] and
he can't even help but just laugh. He's like, "Dude, I can't
even Dude, what the I call this this like too stupid to operate
in this world. And she just up the ante like massively. I don't
know
Is she like a single-issue voter or something? This lady is so
dumb. That's precisely what she is. Guess what her single issue
would be if she's thinks Trump is better in 2024 than 2016.
>> Okay, with that. Dang, it's 10:30. I am tired. >> So
tired. >> Dude, why the [__] would you I Are
you out of your mind?
Bro, he's rolling Dude, this guy is the laziest I've ever seen.
I can't imagine ending a stream making this much money. And everybody's
still clearly just raring to go the whole time.
Bro, I guarantee he's got all the
That's crazy.
To end the stream right now? >> I am tired of making money.
I I look So tired of making money. >> It's it's I I I I
didn't stay here because I was having fun with >> They're saying
I missed one, but I don't see one I missed, gang. I'm I tried
to get them all. Did I miss one? >> Bro, that's crazy.
He actually does just >> $5 from Joelstad. I am publicly
committed to donate to every future WIC TV stream if you agree
to never have PVP, the totally not drunk Kion, ever
>> If we learn Platner only attempted to abuse attempted
abuse, but didn't succeed, would Tally be willing to grade him
on the same scale she uses for attempted coos?
>> Again, I can't believe it. Like you can't look, I choose
the guests based on what I think will make the >> This
guy is very angry.
>> to have on or not have on. Unless unless I have invited
them and they say I have a blacklist. In which case I will honor
that list.
>> I know I'm a screamer. I know the rest of you don't
necessarily enjoy my style. >> Okay. Okay. I love you guys.
I'm going to I'm going to end the show. Thank you to all of you,
especially my panelists who stuck it out in real time for hours.
And thank you. Sorry I didn't get to all the callers, but blame
mostly mostly the panelists and Soy Boy for that. >> Blame
blame me. >> I love you all and I'll talk to you guys later.
Bye-bye. >> Love you. >> That's crazy.
To end to end it there.
That's nuts.